luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show today is going to be pretty interesting
but before we jump in it is powered by icon plus
so quick news announcement for you so this month
icon steve by project balance will be released
a user-friendly platform that creates ics tokens
pegged to real-world assets like the dollar
gold and oil so always really interesting there
it is also sponsored by block fights so i want
to say quick thank you to them um i actually
use them to earn up to 8.6 interest on my usdc
so um i've left a link for you you can get 250
when you sign up so that's pretty cool so joining
me today before i bring him on if you are watching
um on youtube then make sure you hit the like
button and hit subscribe so you never miss any
of these guests now joining me today is author
um he's an entrepreneur um he's the guy with a
bunch of lambos and he's extremely bullish on
twitter and i also believe it's his birthday
today jason what's up happy birthday yeah what's
going on happy birthday like that's so random i
had no idea yeah it happens once a year it's a
it's not it's not that big a deal as you get uh
to this advanced age uh but i'm gonna do some
partying now so you know it's not you know i'm i'm
still uh i'm still trying to get after it so how
have you been i haven't talked to you in a while
yeah i'm good i'm just still not over the fact
that it's your birthday and you're working today
it's very sweet of you yeah this is like
a massive day so it started off with um
beeple and his nft launch on christy
so i was really interested in that
and um you know i was uh i was in the market so
just so i i did go for it you know i'm not going
to say what i bid but i knew some giga chad would
ape in at the end and it did it exactly you know
how i thought it would you know i was a buyer
uh then the price went to 20 like four million
and then with like five minutes left it went to 50
and then it ended up at like 69 million in chain
which is absolutely incredible isn't it like
i don't know where you are with nfts but that
that is an unbelievable situation where people's
like the third like that piece of art is the third
most expensive piece of art by a living artist
so wig but i want to go back a sec because i
saw you were talking firstly really cool glasses
loving the the energy yeah yeah really cool for me
you know i just want to make sure everyone
knows like you see you see someone doing
news you see somebody on some kind of live stream
rocking these glasses you know they're a chad you
know they hold bitcoin so i just want to i
just want to make sure everyone understands
shout out to pit vipers keep sending me these
glasses i'm gonna keep wearing them let's go
why didn't you wear those on fox because i saw
you on fox which i want to talk about but why
weren't you wearing those on fox i tried they
make me take them all they like it no they won't
let me they won't let me do anything they won't
even talk about my book they've never mentioned
the name of my book once well we're going to talk
about that but i want to go into nfts first okay
so what is going on why like where's the value
okay jack's selling his and jack's selling his
tweet what it what is that i can just screenshot
it and then bam my habit like would you pay
that much money for it for a tweet nft
all right so let's step back a second
there are all kinds of people in this
world that like to collect things
and when i was a young kid i like collecting
baseball cards and i still have baseball cards now
you may have collected things i don't know
but those things had value to you and you may
trade them with your friends uh you may actually
try to sell them and i did all of those things
with baseball cards as a young kid i collected
coins proof sets all kinds of things like that
so it's very natural for me to be drawn to digital
collectibles whether it's in-game purchases
digital assets you can own you can gift to your
friends you can pull them out of the game you
can sell them if they're rare you can just keep
them so that you look like an og in the game i
mean all this stuff like makes a lot of sense to
me then you have the advent of digital pokemon
cards potentially there's ether mon that's come
out you've got decentral land which is like buying
digital real estate i've even looked at projects
now that are doing digital franchising so you can
buy some type of revenue generating digital
asset and place it into central land and get paid
you've got nba top shots now and then you have art
right so we're talking about a 370 billion dollar
give or take industry uh the collectible
industry as a whole so it's real um an art
is like a ballers kind of place right you
graduate from collecting baseball cards and
matchbox cars to collecting real art maybe rare
porsches stuff like that and you've got someone
like beeple um really interesting artist has
a really um i think intense following people
have bought into his story these everyday projects
he's been only in the space for like five months
right he's been a digital artist for a long time
3d artist but been in the space for five months
and he starts dropping like absolute fire people
are rushing to get him and then you have today and
yeah yeah hold on let me let me just
close this up you have an ethereum based
project an nft non-fungible token erc 721 contract
and uh he drops his piece of art for 69 million
dollars yeah it's it's mad but have you seen the
backlash that's happening and this is actually
something that i only saw yesterday um but it's
mainly coming from the transgender community and
i couldn't believe it i couldn't i couldn't i was
just like what we just like jumped worlds here so
there's okay so there's two things the first thing
there are issues with regards to energy but that's
always an issue that we hear and a concern when
it comes to bitcoin so that one i don't care about
that one i'm like i'm like whatever that's fine
but the second one was that apparently people are
taking other people's art and they're minting it
into an nft and they're making money from that so
how on earth do you stop against that and
then also what happens if i decide to nft
or min an nft of your tweet isn't there some
copyright issues here or am i missing something
no look i i saw melton was getting all uh
kind of like tweaked and triggered because
people were minting her tweets or something like
that and you certainly can take a screenshot of
one of these projects and mint it on another
platform but here's the thing anything of
value is going to be exploited and art has
historically been ripped off reproduced and
and sold as something it's not it's very easy
to do just a touch of homework to say that
ferocious an artist sold or transferred
that piece of art to me and you can see that
in terms of just the transactions on a
blockchain and that that is the original
piece of art or asset that that's all i have
to say about that if you're if you're going to
screenshot like someone did that this morning
i own a people and i said hey there were 271
of these and he he took a screenshot and said
now they're 272. my whole point is go ahead and
try to sell that you're lying to someone i mean
i definitely agree with you in that this isn't
the first time that you can just copy and
paste somebody's work um like we can talk
about your book because i want to talk about it
i haven't read it yet when i leave the youtube
we're not going to talk i won't talk about
my book to anyone that hasn't read my book
no you know i've got plans to read it i'm getting
it on kindle i haven't prepared you know what i
tell people who don't know how to read just rub it
on your face or something it's that good of a book
i'm leaving i'm i'm i'm leaving the uk when when i
leave that's when i'm reading it right so can you
talk about it we'll talk about it when you read
it sometime because i don't know what you want
to talk about now it'll take you it'll take
you four hours and hopefully it'll it'll be
meaningful to you it's the book nobody mentions
it's the funniest thing i've ever seen it's a
number one bestseller since i launched it i'm
selling these things out of the back of my
out of the back of my trunk and nobody will say
the name of this book and i love that it's uh
it's grown to be uh something you know kind
of uh have its own life so it's pretty cool
i've heard it's had a really good reception as
well like i hear people talking about it all the
time on clubhouse it's it's going down really
well how long did it take you to write well i
started it in the beginning of 2020 finished it
in like november uh brushed it up a little bit
and i think the launch was december 8th december
8th or december 10th so it took me almost a year
but i had i had it on my bucket list to kind of
write a book so it was kind of a cool thing to do
why did you want to do it i don't know like uh i
had the time like this this 2020 being like stuck
in this basement was a bit depressing so um you
know i'm someone who likes to kind of move around
in the world a little bit and that stopped so why
not take the opportunity to uh to write about what
was going on so i i think it's pretty cool read
the book you and i will we'll circle back and
we'll read it and we'll talk about it i'd enjoy
that i'm ready like i have it all prepared on my
kindle that's kind of like my plan when my life is
just karma i'm like i've got three books lined up
yours is one of them um what's going on with you
you're planning to uh to leave um the uk i mean
let's let's talk about that a little bit yeah
we can yeah i mean i i don't like the uk at all
i've never felt a connection with british people
unfortunately um i'm now about a connection with
um the country i'm from london i've never
felt a connection with london at all
so i'm just going well why is it political or
what what's the lack of connection i mean i don't
not feel a connection to the united
states yeah it's a really good question um
i would say gosh it's such a good question i
mean i would say it's political to some extent um
so london is like a very liberal kind of lefty
environment and that doesn't it's not really
in line with with kind of the way i look
at things um and so a lot of people my age
are all all very much like that and i've been
privileged enough to travel the world and
i've seen so many different cultures and so many
different um people the same age as me that just
look at the world the way i look at the world
um and then i came to sort of realize this is
definitely like a london england kind of thing and
then i have the problem whereby i don't know if
you can relate to this but i have this problem
whereby when you're born and bred from in london
it's really really hard to go anywhere else
in the uk it's really hard it's like um it's
like a london-centric thing like when you're a
londoner you you either leave the uk or you stay
well what why don't you go anywhere around
london in such a big city or has uh like a
cultural epicenter i mean what what's the what's
the reason that you guys uh have this big chip
on your shoulder yeah we do it like we're they're
such a north-south divide um so even even with the
with the the manchesters and the leads and from
where you're from but absolutely like i think
it's because london's not just the financial
you know center but also the nightlife is better
there are more there are more bars there are
more restaurants there's just more to do like
if you okay anyone who's listening who's not
from london don't get offended so here we go
it's kind of the way london londoners look
at it it's like you're like downgrading if
you leave because there's just more there's just
more in london there's more options there's more
job opportunities but i don't really care for
it anymore i think london underground is filthy
it's overpriced um and the people are really
unfriendly so where where have you decided to
kind of uh go next okay so i don't want to say it
publicly just yet but i'm looking at the middle
east at the moment um but i don't want to say it
too publicly my end goal is an island that sounds
cool look and the middle east is a place a lot
of uh people from the uk hang out right yeah like
my brother actually just spent about three months
in the middle east um he's in america now which
is very cool so americans be careful my brother's
arrived he's very disruptive um he arrived in lax
last night so he's very disruptive so be careful
um but yeah where were you lost in the uk um
i don't know a year or two ago i mean it wasn't it
wasn't too long ago yeah i was there on business
i was in london and uh i like it very much i
think the skyline's a little weird it's always uh
peculiar you guys have weird like egg-shaped
buildings and stuff the guy i think it's called
the gherkin yeah i don't know i don't even know
what it is never been in it but i was riding
in the train i was like this is the weirdest
looking like uh like montage of weird buildings
yeah i mean i don't know like london's just it
you know what it's filthy it's overpriced and
it's super liberal lefty and i just gotta
get out of here basically and the and the
the weather's terrible so it does
rain a lot i always clown you on that
it does it does but i want to i want to get
your thoughts on bitcoin because you know
we're almost at 60k and your last price
prediction um was wrong which was was fun
wait which which price prediction did i have that
was wrong the halloween one the all-time high on
halloween you can't you can't legitimately
say that i missed that price prediction yes
it was all over it it hit like two weeks later it
was true it made the prediction two years before
october 31st 2020. okay come on come on how was it
feel like fish was it was it all right it wasn't
much of a penalty no it was disgusting like i
i really it's not something i would ever eat
um and i i thought yeah it was it
was pretty gross it was pretty gross
you tried i grew up on uh yeah i grew up
on them you grew up on eating
filet of fish from mcdonald's
come on i don't believe that i
did no i did i did my mom used
it she used to tell me that mcdonald's
was helpful you really do like that
yeah well i don't what i do is i'm really weird
though i do this with burgers as well like i
remove all the bread all the sauce and i just
eat like the meat and the fish on its own um
that's the only reason why i like them all right
otherwise i won't eat all the bread yeah maybe if
it was hot if it was hotter and uh i maybe had
some suggestion of a type of sauce to put on it
but it's nothing i want to i wanted to do again so
yeah to your point i didn't get it exactly right
i ate the filet of fish but i still chalked that
up as a win everybody that put that investment on
made money yeah i mean yeah everyone okay so when
60k what's happening 160k and when 100k um because
your price predictors are on it let's say it yeah
i appreciate that so i um and jul in january like
january 28th i told everyone would be the price
today so we hit that right the big red circle
is going to hit somewhere in there when will we
hit 60k you know uh i think tomorrow tomorrow
yeah i think tomorrow i think yeah i'm pretty
sure i'm pretty sure we hit 60k on the 12th
on the 12th what's the date today the 11th
okay tomorrow i think we hit tomorrow 60k
i mean i don't know how how more specific i could
be i actually love that if we do i'm if we do then
like it's like crazy right it's clowntown yeah
you're going to be looking for classes so you'll
be on it can you send me a pair of those yeah you
read my book and yeah the next time we talk you'll
wear yours i'll wear mine and we'll be able to
see eye to eye like we will have that yeah we will
disconnect though i feel a bit of a disconnect so
i can't see your eyes i know i know it was a late
night i had a soccer match last night i didn't go
to bed till like after midnight i was on clubhouse
i think it's a wild place like there's
a lot of weird stuff going on a lot of
paid shills and implanted agendas and stuff so
you have to you have to go in there with like
like tough as nails like it was the first time i
ever was like openly confronted by one of these
anonymous virgin trolls who lives in their mom's
basement you know he he decided to start screaming
well he started screaming in a room with like 400
people that like i'm a scammer and a [ __ ] coiner
and all that and and i was in there with bitcoin
tina and hoddle and a bunch of like maximalists
so you know i didn't know how to deal with it you
know what did you do well getting in a like text
battle with someone is a lot different than having
someone just screaming like a maniac uh in their
phone so you know my my i think i said very gently
and very calmly and i tapped into my british
uh kind of uh like elite refined amazing dude
you're from you're a mancunian not from manchester
very yeah very very elite and i said look um
if you want to fight me i will pay you 500
000 we'll go anywhere you know i'll go anywhere
in the world i've never seen you you've seen me
i'll donate the 500 000 to whomever you want
whom ever you want right whomever you want
three rounds five minutes virgin nerd i'm gonna
put my hands on you i've never seen you yeah i've
never seen you virgin nerd but we're gonna dance
together it'll be fun i say it'll be fun it's all
for fun but what was his problem i don't get it
i don't understand because uh because i'm done
i'm an investor in block five he thinks i'm a
scammer scamming people and that uh i own uh
i have an investment in the digital asset index
fund that it's one of the products that we had at
morgan creek digital uh like i i you know i don't
even understand what he's talking about i manage
hundreds of millions of dollars professionally
for public pensions those are illiquid investments
i can't come out of them and i don't personally
own that i have nobody also you shouldn't have to
you don't you will that's what i'm
saying it's just a it's a silly argument
you know and i have a lot of respect
for these folks who saw bitcoin early
and got into that investment um but that doesn't
mean they're smart and it doesn't mean that
they they're you know they're good human beings
like none of that so you know i i wish him well
and i'm half joking about dancing with him for
three rounds but i'd watch it i'd watch it yeah
look leah at some point you know if i go to miami
and they're there we're gonna run into each other
you know and i'm gonna see that five foot six
virgin trying to take a shot at some you know
bearded woman and i'm gonna walk up to him wait
why bearded woman wait go back they don't get
that reference i don't know i just feel like
that's how you say it the kind of like woman
he probably would have a shot at i say i'm with
you i'm with you i'm following you yeah i can
and i'm identifying you know as a transgender or
whatever right now so i feel totally comfortable
having this conversation you're such a troll it's
really interesting it's really really interesting
because you're like a grown ass man with like
a wife and kids yeah you come on and you just
troll so hard it's really because because most
people in your position are really professional
no i know but like in a troll way i just want
to have fun like 99 of the stuff i'm saying
like i'm laughing through life life is really hard
people have tremendous pain and if we just smile
a little bit and laugh at ourselves like half
of or 99 of the jokes that i make i just make
fun of myself and i enjoy it but i mean for
me to make a meme uh that i'm a gig of chad
blowing through blowing tinder dates backs
out is the funniest thing in the world
because i don't have any tinder dates no i love it
no i think it's great i like i think it makes you
actually makes you quite untouchable and actually
it's something that i really like because there
are so many trolls online and the best thing to
do is believe it or not in some ways rise to it
like be just as troll troll-ish back like
don't don't try and defend yourself because
that doesn't work don't try and like be the
good person it doesn't work leia i think when
you have strong opinions and you certainly do um
you have to also have like a strong constitution
right you you have to be able to take on the push
right so when you push hard against the earth the
earth pushes earth pushes hard against you and and
i think you have that you you enjoy that you enjoy
these strong opinions and positions and i think
the earth will push hard against you you have to
be prepared for that you don't want to get blown
off the earth especially by people who have loose
opinions or will say gutter ass [ __ ] to you
excuse my language like why let that affect you
you're brilliant you're accomplished you you're
you're you want to learn i think you're very
open-minded you and i don't agree on
tons of stuff i think we get along great
no i'm with you i appreciate that and i really
appreciate that i'm with you who fought for my
peoples i was listening i didn't know what's
coming next but wait i have a question about
bitcoin maximalism for you so firstly
are you a bitcoin maximalist um honestly
and secondly so bitcoin maximalists have kind of
this um this aura whereby i think they feel like
they're the gatekeepers of the world and they're
trying to protect everybody make sure nobody gets
scammed and so on and so on even if somebody's
not shilling anything they're just like even
the fact that you you had the courage to mention
another word that isn't bitcoin is just horrendous
anyway so do you think it actually comes from a
good place do you think they're actually trying
to protect people even though there's really
not much um that they're trying to protect
from particularly when yeah you get my question
yeah i think if i showed up at the gate of the
the bitcoin maximalist citadel and they the the
you know they looked over the gate and they saw
me out there they don't open the gate so i i think
no matter i i don't think that they would think i
was a bitcoin maximalist you know i talk about
nfts i'm an investor in block fi you know i'm
allow for my bitcoin to be rehypothecated not all
of my bitcoin is in self-custody so you get the
picture here um now do i think that they do good
absolutely i think i think bitcoin maximalists are
like on a hero's quest uh most of them have been
but genuinely though genuinely let let me finish
this because there's gonna be douchebags and and
virgins and weirdos that just latch on to it too
because everyone wants to be accepted so you know
if you have point zero zero zero zero one bitcoin
and you wanna hang out with the bully crowd
then you could do that too but most of them
don't have anything do you know that you don't
think they have anything i don't no no i don't
i think i sit in rooms i think i sit in rooms
on clubhouse with you know 10 15 mods who are
teaching people about finance that don't have any
fun they have no financial success or track record
you know i mean seriously i retired when i was
26. wow how did you do that i made a lot of money
and was very focused that cannot be your next
book as well that needs to be your next book
you should but i mean but these little these
little like shots if i pull it out and i shoot it
i would want people to like say maybe i should
listen to this guy not lecture him about why he's
buying nfts right now um but people would rather
they would rather scream at me like oh you're
you're a scammer you're playing hot potato with
people okay i'm telling you that i've seen four
disruptive innovations in my life four one yeah
my own company fast med that i started when i
was at yale dropped out built a company sold for
500 million bucks two the internet you know i'm
there where all the smooth brainers were yuck yuck
on tv about like what's the internet what's this
i saw that today i saw that yesterday though did
you see it was going around like yeah it's crazy
but i saw it in real life it's like nut jobs like
laughing about it right the internet's not gonna
be anything three bitcoin bitcoin alone is another
one of these amazing innovations you're talking
about you know potentially becoming the world's
global reserve currency amazing store of value as
this this kind of evolving asset four i'm throwing
in there nfts oh well i don't know i really do yes
and i don't know i'm agnostic to platform like
i'm not promoting ethereum or promoting wax or
ethernet or super farm or i don't know who's
gonna be right i don't know who's gonna be right
but digital assets are amazing like they are like
this whole thing about being able to trade digital
assets near instantaneously transfer money uh
over blockchain and then certify provenance and
i think is amazing and authenticity it's a really
big deal to a nerd like me who's not a brother
who's not a virgin i'm happy for you i didn't
think he was because you have a few kids yeah
it's not my mom's basement not a virgin not
my mom's basement you know the women i'm with
all of them all four my wife and none of them
have a beard that's what i'm talking about that's
my level up nerds i'm talking about you anyway
can we get at all one day of the house yeah of
course well maybe i people wanted me to do that
but i'm worried about security like i don't want
yeah either inside floor plan of the house yeah
okay i take that back sorry yeah no no worries i
am potentially doing a sh i'm potentially doing a
show though okay i've been asked to check a pilot
yeah like reality tv or yeah it's like a reality
tv show about art like rich people buying art
but they want to introduce
crypto into it like a subplot
okay wait when's this happening i don't know i'm
supposed to talk to people uh tomorrow and kind of
find out the money because i'm not doing stuff for
free like i'm not willing to even shoot a pilot
for free yeah i don't yeah but i mean if they're
gonna do the rolls-royce private jet like put me
in a nice suit and make make believe that i'm an
art art dealer like i'm in like i i'll stick with
like i'll splash this beautiful smile and this
olive skin i'll bring it on tv we could do this
this is like mtv cribs meets crypto meets 2021
style basically i saw i saw the pilot it's wild
these people are wild these are deals i love it
they they're beaut they're beautiful and weird
you'll fit right in but wait i have two
questions i have two questions i want to
ask you the first one i want to go back because so
you mentioned four key things that happened right
how do you spot them like how do you how
do you know nfts is the thing because
gary vee said the similar said a
similar thing he was like yeah i just
i knew it when i saw it with the internet i knew
it when i started with social media i knew it
and he feels the same with nft so how do you
spot that oh he's got the glasses back on well
part of it is every one of these situations leia
was met with violent opposition that's how i know
so i'm i'm hugely emotionally invested in whatever
it is and then when i battle test it or pressure
test it the world is going ape [ __ ] that it's
wrong i'll take you back i'm a physician assistant
i'm doing my residency at yale and i'm thinking
oh i want to hire a bunch of doctors and bring a
retail spin to healthcare people were like that's
the worst idea i've ever heard it'll never work
no doctor is going to work for a pa nobody's going
to go near a starbucks to get their health care
absolutely wrong like every every counter thesis
totally wrong and built it into a huge industry
which then continued to uh to grow and exist today
as a huge part of infrastructure around the world
urgent cares and primary care is using allied
healthcare professionals are a massive business
two the internet you know i won't get into it but
you understand the opposition that was there by
the intellectuals they thought it was insane and
when you started to hypothecate like people will
be buying groceries or ordering uh ordering things
that you would traditionally buy from a store
online like that was clown town like
nobody believed that that would happen
i always underestimate how dramatic this change
would be for people like you because i i grew up
i was born in the 90s digital natives yeah so
but i i mean i remember i had my first mobile
phone it was a nokia when i was maybe like tour no
i was younger because i used to get the school bus
so i was like i don't know 10 or something like
that and even i've seen how it's changed and i'm
shocked yeah leia i mean imagine growing up in
the 1600s in new amsterdam i mean it was a tough
world like it i mean i was there and i was tell me
honestly no no i'm like this is amazing and then
it became seriously no it's uh yeah insane you
didn't have phones when you were teenagers like
you didn't have any social media like dating was
all face to face like even that's bizarre you had
to spend games no amazon you had to be an absolute
giga chad baller that could walk up to a girl
and say you know hey what's up or would you like
to go get coffee or you like go out for dinner
and then you had to continue to converse with
her like you know i mean imagine all that imagine
all that um right the things we've lost tough
stuff no there were no cell phones people had
bag phones and those bag phones were completely
impossible you would never ever use that phone
there were car phones but they were weird they
were like connected by like a wire and they were
only in like ferraris and stuff oh okay yeah they
were um and then there were no personal computers
people had word processors the word processor
the word processor then had an led screen
that was the evolution so you could actually
spell check those are the ballers and then uh
my freshman year college personal computers came
out macintosh and uh what year was that 1992.
oh okay yeah yeah so then yeah a long time ago and
um 1994 the internet you know imagine i'm growing
up there was no computers no computers and then
the internet aol um dial-up internet connections
i mean but you want to talk about an amazing
like experience life experience to which i'm sure
if i was talking to my grandmother she'd say the
same thing but for me as a kid growing up and
then experiencing this expansion of knowledge and
technology has been it's been mind-blowing i mean
no cell phones to bag phone to internet it
wasn't bad it was literally a phone in a
bag you would carry around that was like a
it was like almost like a satellite phone
i know about the bricks i know about the
big bricks you guys used to have no no
it was before that there was a bag with a phone
in it i don't know why it was in a bag but it was
okay i've never heard of this in my life internet
personal computers and think about the people
elon musk jeff bezos uh uh uh bill bill gates
bill gates uh steve jobs that's that's all that's
all my peer group that's all my peer group like
these these guys are all right around the same age
and they made all the cool [ __ ] right so on
top of the internet they built these companies
um and now we've got rockets flying to space i
got starlink for my birthday you know i'm seeing
like crazy stuff i'm booking flights to go to the
moon i added yeah i added on my bucket list that
i'm gonna drive a you know drift a lunar rover
on the moon you know all that kind of stuff so
this is exciting times yeah i think it's i
think it's so insane like even i just think
we underestimate how fast everything's changed
like even when i was younger i used to run home
from school and fight with my brothers about
who can go on msn first to think like you had
to go on msn to speak to somebody instantly and
there was one computer to do it as opposed to
just i mean my phone's like right here you know as
opposed to just like texting is is insane um but
i wanted to ask you because we kind of went
past it 100k for bitcoin last just like been
floating in my head the whole time can we get
that kind of prediction from you and then also
max kaiser says at the end of this year it'll be
200k so yeah give us your thoughts 100k in october
100k in october what 31st uh yeah 100k but this is
this is super conservative i mean uh i'm going to
be way off and low i'm saying 100k by october
31st but i don't really believe that at all i
was expecting 100k this month i'm disappointed
yeah no no i but i don't i i think that we get
far beyond 100k by october 31st but
i'm going with 100k by october 31st
we smashed that 300k we smash 100k
okay we smash 100k i mean i i love
the super cycle chart that shows two
million dollar bitcoin march 21st 2022.
oh wow i haven't seen this yeah but that that
that seems like an impossibility intellectually
because the market cap of bitcoin would have to
be so huge like um that i i just don't see how
it gets there but it's fun to explore so i know
that you have a time limit because you have to
go somewhere um how long do we have because i
have another question for you um stop at 12 20.
12 20. oh that's in like four that's
in four minutes is that i can't see
uh you get oh 12 20. 12 20. i know we've got like
15 yeah okay well 15. okay cool so i wanted to
quickly ask you about gold because um you've
been on fox you've done really well on fox so
congrats i saw you with david goxten and then
you were obviously with peter schiff as well
so let's talk about peter schiff because his son
went a hundred percent um of his portfolio into
bitcoin why can't peter schiff get on board
what is going on and actually gold is down
i was reading today more than 17
percent in the last six months
it go gold is dumb like it's wrong i don't even
understand like um as a as a store of value asset
it's not working anymore and eventually peter's
going to get caught in a short situation where
people start to short gold as the kind of capital
just flows out of it and flows into bitcoin as a
bet that's the better store of value just as i
was talking about the bag phone and you're kind
of smirking and giggling about it and it's even
impossible for you to understand i feel like young
people feel that way about gold like i just can't
imagine you saying you know what i'm gonna go
and buy a safe and i'm gonna bolt the safe to
the wall and the floor and then i'm gonna load
the safe with like i don't know kilos of gold
and silver like i don't even think you want your
life to be that tied down let alone lugging
a pallet of silver around it makes no sense
yeah i mean i think you make a really interesting
point about you're not wanting your life to be
that tied down because i think we're life is
just changing with with you know even with this
whole corona virus the fact that you can now
work almost from anywhere in the world there's
a huge push to get everybody online um we're
moving to this globalist you know this global
no borders kind of world where you can work from
anywhere do you know just work from wherever you
want do whatever you want and also a lot of
people less and less are seeing the value in
buying a property not just because
they can't get on the property ladder
um but also they're just not seeing the value
in it um and so yeah i mean where are they gonna
where are they gonna put their gold anyway like i
don't have i i don't plan on buying a house at all
for a for a long long even if i could or can
maybe not maybe i can afford it it doesn't matter
i don't want to buy one at all but leia is
that because you don't want to be tied down
or is it because you think about things
in bitcoin like price things in bitcoin
it's two things so firstly like i don't want to
be tied down and even when i'm married i also
feel like the kind of person that i would choose
i don't really want to be fully tied together
i don't want to be you know tied to a country
i'd want to be able to like move with him and
go wherever we want to go in terms of in terms
of bitcoin i also don't want to sell it i like
i don't want to sell it but michael and michael
has been talking about taking a loan out on your
bitcoin and so on and so on i don't understand
that so can maybe you explain that yeah i i think
um and i'll go back to the 1600s in new amsterdam
so if we were fortunate no but i'm serious pl play
the game with me if we were if you and i had
arrived there and then i was able to project
forward history uh into the future with you and
say hey this is going to eventually be new york
and every piece of land here will be a city block
and we can buy those city blocks right now for 500
and you and i had wealth because we came from
wherever the new amsterdam people came from
and we bought a bunch of city blocks everybody
that owns new york city blocks never sold those
new york city blocks now that's a pretty illiquid
asset but it is priceless so how do you pass this
priceless illiquid asset on to the next generation
the next generation next generation you have to
use leverage you have to be creative you have to
do things to maintain it but profit from it that's
what we all will do with bitcoin like you'll
borrow against your bitcoin you'll put it in an
oh how do you do that well you could do it right
now with block fi you can you can take a loan uh
you can pledge like 50 loan to value and you can
pull cash out and you can do something with that
cash now i don't necessarily recommend that people
do that but i'm saying it's a certainly an option
to do the other thing you can do is you can gain
interest on your bitcoin so you can earn money
on it that way but you should just continue
to think about how rich people protect their
assets and take illiquid assets and make them
work for them and work beyond just appreciating
right because bitcoin is not only good money
it's sound money but it's also this amazing
like apex predator asset that can grows and has
grown 200 percent historically year-over-year
um uh and i i just think it's an amazing thing
you don't want to sell it and i appreciate you
saying that you know you you hold like you do
um but uh yeah i have no interest in selling
like seriously i have no interest and i just i've
only because obviously i'm not american i've only
recently heard the term 401k um because i we don't
have that here we have our own um equivalents
um i don't want any of that i don't want any of
it like the amount of tax that you have to pay
when you want to remove it i've seen too many
bad things happen to generations before me so i
i'm just like no i i don't do you have a
retirement plan right now bitcoin yeah i get it
and i was gonna say i'm sorry to interrupt
you like you're you have a lot of different
revenue streams through your show and sponsors
etc do that don't ever feel bad about that
and get paid in bitcoin or convert that fiat
into bitcoin i mean i know you're doing that
bravo come into the rooms in in clubhouse that
i'm in that are rooms about capitalism and how to
uh make money and not just you know shame
people that are holding you know that that
uh don't just hold bitcoin i i mean that's fine
if that's what you want to do but i think there's
there are other people looking for mechanisms
that grow faster than bitcoin and there there are
ways and strategies to to uh to make money
greater than 200 percent annual so i love it well
ping me in i want to come in i want to learn i'm
always happy to to learn more so yeah ping me in
that's cool that's cool all right well look i
appreciate this uh i hope i was a good fill-in
uh who who was slacking today that was
supposed to be here that you called on me
so firstly thank you so much for joining this
has been super fun it's been really chilled
i know it has like it's been really chilled i
really like it and i was going to prepare but
you told me not to prepare and i'm glad i didn't
this has been really fun um a girl called an old
school i know how to talk to a woman i see i see
there you go that's that's that's what you did
it was supposed to be um dominique samuels who's a
really cool person she's british and she's really
into the politics scene she's mixed race and
she's very much auntie blm um and so has some
really really cool views so i was excited to chat
to her but a last minute pull out so but yeah it
was great having you on so i want to thank you so
much and i want to thank everybody for watching
and really quickly where can people find you
and what are you up to where can people find
you well i would like to if you would have me
if you ever have someone who is coming on your
show that has extreme thoughts like that i would
love for you to have the two of us on and i would
never be confrontational but both as a learning
experience because anytime i hear you know people
that have a different opinion than me i like to
be around them i would enjoy uh asking questions
in a non-confrontational environment where i
could learn or maybe challenge someone whom
i think uh maybe has it wrong and maybe i do
too so yeah absolutely cool absolutely thanks
so much for coming on and thank you everybody
for watching we'll see you next week bye see ya